WAY YOU DO WITH PEOPLE THAT
ARE AGAINST YOU, PRETTY SMART,
CLEVER.
CHAIRMAN OF JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
LED TODAY'S HEARING AND DID A
PHENOMENAL JOB.
I WOULD SAY ON A SCALE OF
1 TO 10, YOU AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL GET A THOUSAND.
THAT LIST THAT YOU WENT DOWN,
THAT IS THE HEADLINE.
THIS IS OVER.
HE'S NOT CHANGING HIS MIND AND
THIS IS ALL BEGINNING.
>> TELL ALL MY FRIENDS ON THE
OTHER SIDE, WE GAVE MUELLER TWO
YEARS TO DO HIS JOB.
HE HAD 19 LAWYERS.
HE HAD $25 MILLION AND
INTERVIEWED 500 PEOPLE AND
ISSUED 2,000 SUBPOENAS.
HE HAD PLENTY OF OPPORTUNITY
WITHOUT INTERFERENCE.
THE PRESIDENT GAVE HIM A MILLION
AND A HALF DOCUMENTS AND
EVERYBODY AROUND THE PRESIDENT
AND THE PRESIDENT'S CAMPAIGN
TESTIFIED VOLUNTARILY AND HERE
IS WHAT WE KNOW.
THERE WAS NO CONSPIRACY BETWEEN
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND RUSSIANS
AT ALL.
THE MUELLER COULD NOT DECIDE
CHOSE NOT TO PRESS FORWARD ON
OBSTRUCTION.
I ALWAYS THOUGHT OBSTRUCTION
ARGUMENT WAS ABSURD.
IT IS OVER.
THE REASON THEY ARE MAD AT BARR
AND ME IS BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
GET THE OUTCOME THEY WANT.
MY FRIENDS ON THE OTHER SIDE
WANT OUT, AND THEY DON'T CARE
HOW THEY GET IT.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, SENATOR,
I'VE KNOWN YOU A LONG TIME.
I WANT YOU TO DELVE INTO THAT
LINE OF QUESTIONING THAT I PLAY
FOR YOU WENT ON YOUR LIST BUYS A
ABUSE, THE RIGGED CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION INTO HILLARY.
IT WAS ALL RIGGED.
SHE DID VIOLATE THE ESPIONAGE
ACT, AND IT WAS CLASSIFIED TOP
SECRET INFORMATION ON THE
SERVER.
SHE HAD AN INTENT BY BLEACH BIT
AND HAMMERS AT POINTS AND CARDS
BUT THE INTENT WAS TO DESTROY
THE EVIDENCE.
OBSTRUCTION WHICH THE VERY THING
LIBERALS ARE CARING ABOUT, THAT
WOULD BE A SLAM DUNK OBSTRUCTION
CASE TO ME.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> Lindsey: WHEN I TRIED TO
SHOW, WHEN IT CAME TO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN WE HAD BOB MUELLER ONE
OF THE MOST EXPERIENCED LAWYERS
FROM A FORMER FBI DIRECTOR, TAKE
TWO YEARS, $25 MILLION, 19
LAWYERS.
EVERYBODY IN THE COUNTRY BELIEVE
HE WAS A FAIR-MINDED GUY AND HE
REACHED A CONCLUSION THAT THE
LEFT DOES NOT LIKE.
BUT THE VERDICT IS IN FOR
MUELLER.
NO COLLUSION.
NO OBSTRUCTION.
NOW, WHAT I TRY TO SHOW THE
PUBLIC THAT WHEN IT CAME TO
CLINTON, CLINTON'S EMAIL
INVESTIGATION THERE WAS NO BOB
MUELLER, AND HATED TRUMPS GUTS
AND WANTED TO WIN HUNDRED
MILLION TO NOTHING BUT I WANTED
TO KNOW IF I SO WARRANT OBTAINED
AGAINST CARTER PAGE BASED ON
GARBAGE, COLLECTED BY FOREIGN
AGENT PAID FOR BY THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IT IS UNVERIFIED TO THIS DAY.
AND I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
THEY OPEN UP A COUNTER
INTELLIGENCE INVESTIGATION
AGAINST PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR BAD
MOTIVES?
WE WILL GET THE ANSWERS TO THOSE
QUESTIONS.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, I THINK
THIS IS IMPORTANT AS WELL.
OKAY, SO THE ISSUE FINDING OUT
WITH THAT THEY RIGGED THE
CLINTON INVESTIGATION --
>> Lindsey: YEAH.
>> Sean:
WE Sean:
WE Wean:
WE WENn:
WE WENT THE SAME TIME
INTERESTING TO ORIGINATE THIS
CROSS FIRE HURRICANE.
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE PFIZER
ABUSE, NOW "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
SUGGESTING IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN
PAID FOR RUSSIAN INFORMATION?
WHILE MATT, THAT IS A BIG DEAL
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, DO YOU
BELIEVE AS I DID THAT A FRAUD
WAS COMMITTED ON THE FISA COURT,
FISA APPLICATIONS.
I READ SOMETHING, GRAHAM MEMO
THE BULK APPLICATION AND FISA
APPLICATIONS WAS THE PAID FOR
DOSSIER THAT MIGHT BE RUSHING
THIS INFORMATION?
IS THAT TRUE, SIR?
>> Lindsey: I KNOW THAT
McCABE SAID WITHOUT THE
DOSSIER THAT THERE WOULD BE NO
WARRANT.
I KNOW TO THIS DAY THERE IS NO
THIS -- VERIFICATION OF THE
DOSSIER, GARBAGE AND THE PEOPLE
CERTIFIED THAT IT WAS RELIABLE.
I KNOW THAT JAMES COMEY THE FBI
DIRECTOR AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP
GAVE HIM THE SAME DOSSIER AND
TOLD THE PRESIDENT WE CAN'T
VERIFY.
WE JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW ABOUT
IT.
THAT DOESN'T ADD UP.
WE WILL LOOK AT ALL OF THAT BUT
HERE'S WHAT I DO KNOW.
NOBODY CARES WHEN THE OTHER
SIDE, WHAT THE FBI DID OR DIDN'T
DO WHEN IT COMES TO CLINTON.
THEY DON'T CARE WHAT THEY DID OR
DIDN'T DO WHEN IT COMES TO
TRAUMA.
THEY ARE TRYING TO DESTROY HIS
PRESIDENCY.
FROM THEIR POINT OF VIEW THE
RULE OF LAW IS THE TOOL TO GET
AN OUTCOME.
FROM MY POINT OF VIEW RULE OF
LAW PROTECTS ALL OF US INCLUDING
PRESIDENT TRUMP INCLUDING
REPUBLICANS.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW SOMETHING
SIMILAR -- SENATOR ONE OF YOUR
FINEST MOMENTS IN THE CABINET HA
FINEST MOMENTS IN THE CABINET HI
FINEST MOMENTS IN THE CABINET HG
FINEST MOMENTS IN THE CABINET H,
IT WAS INTERESTING A LOT OF EYE
BELIEVERS ON THE MOST OUTRAGEOUS
ALLEGATION.
WE HAVE SERIOUS ALLEGATIONS NOW
ABOUT THE ATTORNEY, I'M SORRY
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR OF THE
COMMONWEALTH OF VIRGINIA, AND
VIOLENT SEXUAL ASSAULT BY TWO
WOMEN.
I DON'T HEAR THE EYE BELIEVERS
AND I SAY DONALD TRUMP GAVE
EVERY AMERICAN $5 MILLION
TONIGHT AND THE LIBERAL AGENDA,
THEY HATE HIM, AM I WRONG?
>> Lindsey: YOU ARE RIGHT AND
IT SAID.
BIPARTISANSHIP IS TO BE NICE TO
THEIR PEOPLE, BOTH FOR THEIR
JUDGES, SET ON THE SIDELINES
WHEN DESTROY A TRUMP JUDGE.
TO GIVE MUELLER SPACE TO DO HIS
JOB IS NOT ENOUGH.
WHEN MUELLER GIVES AN ANSWER